im zusammenhang mit den kriegerischen
ereignisse in der ost ukraine fällt
immer wieder der begriff eingefrorene
konflikte bestätigte ja die frage was
macht eingefrorene konflikte so brisant
[Musik]
der begriff eingefrorene konflikte
bezieht sich auf konflikte aus der zeit
der auflösung der sowjetunion und der
unabhängigkeit ehemalige sowjetische
staaten
teile dieser neuen unabhängigen staaten
wollten sich damit nicht abfinden und
haben versucht eine eigene
unabhängigkeit anzustreben und wurden
dabei ganz massiv von russland
unterstützt
dazu gehören die transnistrische
republik in der republik moldau dass die
südossetien und abchasien in der
republik georgien
auch der konflikt um nagorny karabach
kann hier in diesem kontext gesehen
werden
russland spielt dabei eine ambivalente
und zentrale rolle denn einerseits hat
es diese aufständischen gruppierungen
die sezessionistischen gruppierungen
militärisch politische und auch
wirtschaftlich massiv unterstützt auf
der anderen seite nütze es natürlich
diese gelegenheit ihr einfluss zu nehmen
und die eigene position im raum der
ehemaligen sowjetunion zu festigen und
auch in die nachbarschaft ausstrahlen zu
können
was ist nun das problem mit diesen
eingefrorenen konflikten zuerst einmal
ein staat der davon befallen ist
konzentriert sich fast ausschließlich
auf diesen konflikt das heißt irgendwas
dir den sicherheit polizei militär und
weniger in entwicklung infrastruktur
bildung und soziales zbfs überwachten
seiner souveränität eingeschränkt und
außenpolitisch hatte das große manko
dass er eigentlich nicht
gleichberechtigt ist es kann kein staat
mit einem eingefrorenen konflikt glauben
also zum beispiel in die eu oder in die
nato aufgenommen werden kann
dazu kommt noch ein anderes problem
eingefrorene konflikte sind nur an der
oberfläche eingefroren irgendwann
brechen sie wieder auf und wir sehen
dass immer wieder in agonie karabach und
wir sehen das auch eben in georgien 2008
wo versucht wurde militärisch
südossetien zurück zu erobern
russland sofort zurück geschlagen hat
und südossetien in georgien de facto
verlorenes eingefrorene konflikte sind
eine hypothek für die zukunft sie sind
gift für die entwicklung eines landes
und das macht es wirklich so schwierig
und problematisch
es ist daher verständlich wenn man in
der ukraine die angst hat dass der
konflikt im osten im dorf einfriert und
daher auch eine ähnliche problemlage
entsteht
aber dazu in einer anderen folge